the Joe Rogan experience there's
different styles of MMA our rather of
martial arts that enter into MMA and
become effective let way the only thing
that's missing is the head butts from
MMA you know you have this one element
of your game that you wouldn't really be
able to mess that that you know what I
was joking that a long time before I
could receive these these serious offers
for murder and memory promotion I was
like if I go one day I'm just gonna
headbutt the guy and get disqualified
and then it's gonna go viral it's gonna
help that's before I think one Fc would
probably allow head butts from oh I do
wait when if C is actually partnered up
with WLC they're there they're very
friend with the CEO that's the things
that make sense yeah and what makes
sense because they allow soccer kicks on
the ground even inside okay he actually
had to literally exhibit in that
exhibition fight but led to a super
fight one inside of one of their shows
in one is a real an EMR oh that makes
sense
just to showcase the culture sure sure
yeah I just see if I feel like if
someone like you fought over there I
mean they have such open rules I mean
they have more Thai fights with MMA
gloves they have regular kickboxing they
have regular movie message me for that
they wanted me to fight Muay Thai I
don't want to fight with I come I want
to I said I want to file it we is that
well even if I look to it go to CC and
that's when we started getting the long
win well they're doing grappling
competitions in one Fc as well they they
seem to be open to almost any martial
yeah yeah for sure and also eSports now
like that's the future why he's a good
shot tree is a good fight is a good
doing eSports yeah so out of one eSports
no he's ahead of the wave yeah because
it's gonna be the future Wow what games
I don't know what fighting schemes like
street fighting games oh my god that's
hilarious if it became huge would they
have the UFC and 1 FC 5 a UFC no but I
mean if they had the UFC videogame okay
we're playing the UFC video game on this
fort in in 1 FC that would be hilarious
I really would yeah oh my God look at
that
that's eSport yes oh [ __ ] ok one
championship launches Asia's biggest
eSport World Championship Ayesha trees
is just a smart visionary for this like
yeah look at the size of that
Arina that this nothing shocks me more
than the massive popularity of eSports
in terms of as a spectator sport not in
terms of people playing it I get a total
price like five hundred thousand dollars
and late for eSports so they're not go
to the other side go to the other side
Jamie let me see that picture look at
that oh my look at that that's a game
[ __ ] crazy
Warcraft I don't know is that what it is
yeah yeah in dota 2 this game I don't
play so we don't even know the game and
they win the half a million dollars for
this there's like 14 years old 15 years
old these guys yeah I mean there's real
money in video games now before we're
parents would say you're wasting your
time go play golf you can make money no
you can make money playing video game
you play games I do but I get addicted
to yeah I have real playing like like a
day non-stop oh you have [ __ ] giant
problems we set up a lab where you're
laughing it's true he knows yeah sort of
see how much you cos gonna tell you but
yeah real problem are you an extremist
like if you do something you do it like
yeah I got real problems man like look
if I want to get good at something my
brain it's good because my obsessiveness
allows me to really concentrate on
excellence okay but the problem is like
there's no benefit for me getting really
good at quake championship you know
that's the game we're playing right was
it quake
champions you're quake champions yeah
that's we're playing we've got a land
room set up back then we play it yeah
sweaty hand twitch okay we're out there
playing but I'm just we're just playing
but against each other okay for fun yeah
man but it's not fun okay the problem is
I mean is the game what is very first
person shooter know you've rocket
launchers and rail guns yeah it's
definitely fun don't get me wrong but
what's not fun is the amount of time
that it takes and how I crazy I get
where I'm like in the middle of the
night I'm thinking about playing it
gonna be three o'clock the more I've
come down here like I gotta do something
I've worked out I can't like I'll leave
my house I'll come down here to work out
it I'll work out the gym and sit [ __ ] it
let me jump online get out next you know
I'm here for four hours just playing
awake yes then Jamie knows he's seen it
look he's laughing is it like you're
Neil Peart is it monsters or real people
outs it's you know robots and people
with like you know like cyborgs and [ __ ]
with crazy
outfits on but that's the point is it's
a first-person shooter so you're in this
3d environment it's a mouse and a
keyboard and you're running down these
hallways and it's a lot of strategy
involved a lot of fast twitch movement
in an aim but it's very very addictive
and it's graphically very intent
beautiful little boys we already been
dad all right
yes what's up yeah one of the companies
that makes one of the really big esports
games just announced that they're
working on a their first first-person
shooter I think it's their first
first-person shooter they did announce a
title that just sort of showed a couple
things that working on it's gonna not
that you're gonna get back into it but
it could get you back into it right
there man the product can't do it I had
a quick cold turkey we were doing how
many months where we're going out of
everyday Solid 3 for everyday men hours
everyday with Jamie like laughed he's
like you guys put in more time me and
Jeff works here
we're playing so much we put in more
time in like how it was yeah like in
like three or four I had the game on my
computer at home for about a year
playing it just off and on here and
there to probably put in like 30 or 40
hours overtime playing they passed me in
like three weeks
but I had a problem like that with
everything with jujitsu Taekwondo with
Muay Thai everything that I get into
pretty much that's a good trait but as
long as you can handle it yeah you got
to know how to handle it like for me
it's like I got to know when to cut
things off if I stop stop stop stop stop
so for me with the video games like no
cut it out because it was just eating I
don't have any time man and I have kids
have family and I have three jobs I just
don't I don't have a time for these
[ __ ] video games but I like them too
much no I finally like up now I got that
my phone on the airplane could be like
literally like 20 airplanes this like
this last couple weeks oh you play games
on your phone at like a castle defense I
just like I don't have any games on my
phone except my kids play games on my
phone sometimes I don't have any [ __ ]
what are you doing an airplane you just
sleep
I read okay I read or write I write you
know comedy material and stuff or write
things about watch a movie maybe but I
don't play any games I just I don't I
just don't trust myself okay just get to
a dick quick yeah yeah
you should [ __ ] play it with us
sometime my god we had yeah man I'm
telling you it's super dick I think
obsession is key for any success yeah
and I think every successful people is
eccentric a little bit yes I'm [ __ ]
weird of yours
yeah we're both crazy it's important
it's yeah yeah I think you have to be
crazy to dedicate massive amounts of
time to something and be obsessed yeah
it's to acquire excellence in anything I
believe it requires a real genuine
obsession where that becomes a primary
focus of your life but when you have a
finite amount of time like I do yeah
because I already have a career I have
things that I must do and I don't want
to I don't want to slack off and become
a bad podcaster and become a bad
comedian and fall apart in the other at
things that I'm focusing on because I'm
focusing on a game let's choose can
imagine yeah I know yeah it doesn't help
me see
jiu-jitsu helps me yeah like when I
train I feel more calm I get better
perspective I I feel like there's
something that I am get I gain and also
you can only do it a certain amount of
hours a day you can't do jiu-jitsu six
hours in a row you can't but you could
play video games ten hours in a row
twelve you just keep going yeah this guy
was like playing video games then and
they die people die they die they have
[ __ ] heart attacks and die it's very
very intense like sometimes we leave and
I don't even feel good like we leave and
I feel all [ __ ] up and you sat at your
you're unhappy about your cellulite why
do this you wasted a lot of time and
also like your system is so taxed
because it's so intense you know and
we're talking mad [ __ ] you sure it's a
lot of fun did you see that
just made me think of this there an
article about the amount of calories
that Chessmaster burns yes I saw that I
was saying like that they lose
incredible amounts of weight during
these tournaments in there well they're
just realizing now that this is a
calorie thing that your brain when
you're under intense focus your brain
burns off a shitload of calories so
that's why we lose a lot of calories I
think yes mark I thank you yeah but I
really think that that's the same thing
with video games as well
I mean I get out of your mouth [ __ ]
exhausted sometimes when we
we were in those rambling places you
should go into that Eastport thing [ __ ]
that hey there's not enough lives to
live you know that's what I understand
when people say they're bored I'm like
how can you be bored there's so many
things to do
true you know there's so many things you
can get obsessed with yeah you know
[Applause]